[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الشهر السابع من شهور السنه العربيه بين
قوسين الهجريه يسمى برجب ورجب ماخوذ من
الرجوب اي التعظيم فقد كانت العرب تعظم
هذا الشهر واكثر القبائل تقديسا لهذا
الشهر هم قبيله مضر ولهذا يسمى برج ابو
مضر وهو احد الاشهر الحرم الاربعه محرم
ورجب وذا القعده وذا الحجه وهي الاشهر
التي يحرم فيها العرب القتال الا دفاعا عن
النفس وعن ارض الوطن بلاد الالفناها على
كل حاله وقد يؤلف شيئ الذي ليس بالحسن
ونستعذب الارض الذي لا هوى بها ولا ماؤها
عذب ولكنها
وطن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واشهر يوما انجيل الطيبين واحد سبعه فهو
موعد ميلاد معظم السعوديين منذ عقود فهم
يشتركون باليوم والشهر ويختلفون بالسنه
ورجب لهذه السنه نصها الاول شباط مقطع
ارباط ونصفها ثاني العقارب اولاد العقارب
ترى الخير
جارم
[موسيقى]